il n'y a encore que de l'herbe avec une
vue imprenable sur le château de
versailles dans quelques années
sept ans précisément les cavaliers et
leurs montures s'affronteront ici pour
les épreuves d'équitation djo laura
flessel la ministre des sports est venu
visiter les futurs sites olympiques du
château de versailles qui doit
accueillir également le pentathlon
moderne
on a cette chance de valoriser gérer le
château de versailles géré au niveau
international lorsqu'on va partir à
l'international va nous poser des
questions sur les lieux qui vont
recevoir les jeux et aujourd'hui le
château de versailles je connaissais
mais lorsqu'on a cette transposition et
et qu'on voit je dirai comment on va
utiliser à gérer pour le futur bon on
est fier est déjà l'un des sites les
plus visités de france le château de
versailles profitera forcément de
l'effet jo
si les travaux n'ont pas débuté le
projet pas encore totalement arrêtée
des tribunes seront construites pour
accueillir jusqu'à 20000 personnes
de quoi craindre d'éventuelles
dégradations des lieux mais la direction
la sueur et rassure
l'histoire du monument sera préservé 6au
s'engage évidemment à respecter tout
l'intégrité de ce lieu je crois même que
ça n'a pas fait la moindre discussion
pour personne quand les membres du cio
sont venus ici
il connaissait le château de versailles
il voyait que c'est ce lieu était resté
dans son intégrité depuis le xviiie
siècle qu'on ne pouvait rien n'est
changé
en plus du château de versailles le
département des yvelines accueillera
d'autres épreuves olympiques notamment
celle du cyclisme sur piste au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines